she turns her experiences into music
into notes even the protests in her home
country turkey
these days composer zaineb ki disliolu
lives and works in berlin
the kreutzberg district of berlin
noisy chaotic full of contradictions the
perfect place to work
it helps me focus once i even finished
composing one of my piano pieces called
divant etlang in the airport
her most recent work is called durak it
was commissioned by deutsche welle for
this year's beethoven festival in bonn
her compositions are known for their
precision and uncompromising attention
to detail
is at home in the international new
music scene she was born in izmir
studied in istanbul zarb looking
strasbourg and carls lua and spent a
year doing research in paris
i can't even really imagine living in a
place where i'd say this is where i'll
stay where i belong
and for me being rootless is something
good useful productive
when zainebkidisliolu left turkey 12
years ago her piano stayed in istanbul
she taught herself how to compose
without an instrument she does her best
work in public places like cafes and
libraries
and her music changed too as a result it
grew more complex bolder and more
experimental
all i need is myself
my mind which gives me the imagination i
need to create my works this is a handy
forced and can
and
a pencil
some paper
and it helps to have an eraser
shortly after she began working on the
commission last may the people of
istanbul took to the streets they
demanded more freedom more democracy and
self-determination the police responded
to the demonstrators with brutality and
force
suddenly the place she'd left behind
turkey was calling to her
but what was i supposed to do
just quit what i was doing buy a gas
mask and go to istanbul and be useful
nuts
the title of her new work durak has
several meanings in turkish a break a
decisive step a phase a word that
captures the dichotomies of her work
this is my natural this is my language
music
and that was the decision i faced
will i take to the streets
or will i choose a more solitary slow
path of trying to find something to say
music is her language but that path too
didn't happen overnight
kadisliolu's parents are both artists
but not musicians her mother's an
actress and theater director her
stepfather is a painter
when she was eight zainab discovered her
parents record collection rock music
nothing classical but it captivated her
like nothing else
music can transform your entire life
it's a kind of vitality that you
suddenly discover and feel within
yourself
you didn't even realize it and then
there it is
it can be a moment an experience
and all of a sudden your entire world
has changed
unlike many other composers zaineb
kudisliolu doesn't use a computer or
simulation software to create her work
she doesn't actually hear her finished
piece until it's time for rehearsal
that's another thing i love about my
career
it's part of what makes it so exciting
the first rehearsal is really a magical
experience
she composed durak for the students of
the istanbul university orchestra it's
the first time the young musicians are
performing contemporary classical music
come on
it's a demanding work for the performers
and the audience
but the premier is a success the turkish
ambassador is a bit more restrained in
his applause he's less than pleased
about the political implications of the
work
durak also represents a break a rupture
for the composer herself she's a musical
nomad but now turkey her homeland and
the protest there have taken up
residence in her work the result is a
powerful statement set to the language
of music
you